‘Going for an Indian’
or ‘having a curry’
is almost as stereotypically British
as roast dinners or fish and chips.
There are around 12,000
curry houses in Britain.
The word came from the Tamil ‘kari’,
which meant a spiced sauce.
But gradually the term was
adapted and used as a generic term
for any stew-like food
from the Indian subcontinent -
rather ignoring such subtleties as,
regional differences
and completely different flavours,
textures, cooking methods
and ingredients.
The first definite mention
of ‘curry’ in English is in 1598.
But the first recipe for curry
published in Britain
wasn’t until 1747,
by which time Brits,
long-time traders with India,
were slowly taking over the country.
Thousands of British men and women
spent time in India.
They had Indian cooks and servants,
and while some tried to maintain
Western eating habits,
most quickly embraced
the tastes of their new home.
When they returned to Britain,
they brought their new love
of Indian food back with them.
Those who had lived in India
knew very well that not all
Indian dishes were curry,
and when the first,
albeit short-lived
Indian restaurant in Britain
opened in London in 1810,
its menu contained khichdi, chutnee and pulao...
dishes later known by the anglicised
names, kedgeree, chutney and pilaf.
Manuscript books,
kept by those in the know,
also differentiated between dishes.
But they were very much
a minority, and in Britain,
curry became a catch-all term for
almost anything with Indian spices.
Slowly certain dishes,
especially chicken curry -
which used an elderly fowl,
which had stopped laying eggs -
entered the mainstream repertoire.
Ready-made curry powders
were widely sold.
British palates
were not used to Indian spices,
and the early recipes are more
like gently flavoured meaty stews,
laden with turmeric, ginger and
galangale, with cayenne for a hit.
By the 19th Century,
curry was in every cookbook,
mainly as a leftover dish.
The Anglo-Indian cuisine
of this era was a hybrid,
using pickled cucumbers to replace
mango, apple instead of tamarind,
and ready-made spice blends galore.
It was great, but had very little
in common with its Eastern roots.
Queen Victoria
took a different approach,
regularly eating ‘Indian dishes’
prepared by the cook
to her Indian attendants,
who’d joined the royal staff
at her Golden Jubilee in 1887.
There were a few eating houses
run by Indians,
mainly for other Indians,
in port towns,
but it took until the 1920s
for high profile restaurants to open,
catering for a British market.
By 1946 there were around
20 Indian restaurants in London.
Boomtime for curry
came after the Second World War,
when the partition of India
brought migrants
from Punjab and Sylhet to Britain.
In the 1970s,
civil war in Bangladesh saw
many Bangladeshis flee to Britain,
and even today many
apparently generic Indian restaurants
are really Bangladeshi.
Curry, in its 1970s form,
was cheap and cheerful,
adapted for British tastes.
In 2001 the then foreign secretary,
Robin Cook
declared boldly that Britain’s national dish was chicken tikka masala…
a classic example of an
Indian dish - buttered chicken -
meeting British tastes,
in this case with the addition
of cream and, allegedly,
cream of tomato soup.
In the last decade or so,
the British relationship
to Indian food has changed.
Most of us have grown out
of wanting something so hot
it’ll hospitalise us.
Leading Indian chefs are teaching us
that there is so
much more to Indian food
than the comforting predictability
of the average restaurant menu.
Maybe after 250 years,
we’ve simply come full circle.